[Applause]
you're so pregnant
[Music]
i'm about to check the baby
i'm already so in love with this birth
center like they're so like they're way
more thorough i don't want to feel like
a whole person here
[Music]
of your uterus which is called your
fungus
so that's actually the top of your
universe so your uterus went from being
under your beautiful
hi nice to meet you
hi
congratulations
[Music]
we're heading over to my surprise baby
shower
that isn't very much of a surprise well
i planned it and she's so cute she's so
excited that she's not really good
that's so cute oh we came from the birth
center our new birth center which i
absolutely loved and the midwife that we
met with she was amazing like oh my god
instant connection loved her vibe loved
everything about her and they're just so
much more thorough they made me feel
like a whole person not just like a
patient even at the other birth center
it was like it was better than the
hospital for sure like
than a doctor but amongst birth centers
this was better months burst centers oh
my god this one like we upgraded like
crazy so true yeah i feel good so like
in the previous vlog we said our birth
center was closing down on us like just
out of nowhere and we were kind of like
panicking a little bit problem solved we
found the new one
surprise
oh our baby it's not my baby shower it's
our baby shower
true
oh yeah she put so much effort and like
excitement into planning this so i'm
like what she wanted me
[Applause]
tears
surprise
wants tears the whole the whole the
whole world
[Music]
[Music]
you guys are tickling the baby
[Laughter]
yesterday was our baby shower which was
so freaking sweet of my mom to throw for
us like she worked so hard on this baby
shower it was just really awesome to see
anyone that was able to make it because
it ended up being on a tuesday so it was
tuesday the 28th which is also in
between christmas and new year so there
were a lot of people out of town for the
holidays but yeah my mom was really
really thoughtful and considerate she
was trying to accommodate for when the
tan clan are here because they flew in
for the holidays so she was like oh it'd
be a good time to throw the baby shower
so that's the reason why it was
yesterday it was really funny that my
mom like she loves juan gabriel who's a
really really famous singer from mexico
who has already passed she saw this juan
gabriel impersonator a few months back
and she's just like super obsessed with
this dude so he she thought like oh my
god they would absolutely love a
performance from him so she booked him
and it was it was definitely a surprise
so it was really it was really sweet
that she decided to to incorporate that
into the party so that's who that person
performing is because everyone like our
guests were like so is this person
famous like are you a big fan of this
guy and i'm like no but my mom really
loves them so
she had a great time with him so that
was awesome it was really nice to like
be with family be with really close
friends and just get to shower this baby
which by the way i'm 31 weeks and
yeah this baby still has two more months
to go so it's really exciting now we get
to one did we uh coordinate on purpose
today
no i mean if i'm wearing orange and
you're wearing pink but it's pretty
close i would argue that you're a
farm-raised standing and i'm wild caught
sandwich
we're both seven colors
no yeah that was an accident it was cute
because earlier we were both wearing our
green puffy jackets and we totally
matched i don't know i'm just thinking
like we're like it's so into each other
i know i love it we're soulmates that's
why so we got our presents here look at
that this is so cool it's christmas
again yeah we get to open more presents
it's weird thinking about it but i was
like oh the baby shower is kind of like
a birthday party for the baby but it's
not on their birthday yeah on the
birthday like there are no presents like
like the baby coming out is is the thing
you know so there's something else you
should be doing yeah but happy birthday
yeah we're celebrating your birthday two
months early and you've been kicking a
lot today and you were kicking so much
yesterday it was so cute like you could
hear the music and then the the kids
playing with my belly it was so cute
you've definitely been enjoying this
celebration for you can't wait to see
your reaction in the future when you see
this because then we get to know who you
are and what your name is
everyone's asking us like do you guys
have names
maybe they're in the future they'd be a
huge juan gabrielle fan imagine they
come out that's perfect but anyways
before we begin uh i just want to say
huge thank you for everyone like
all of our loved ones uh coming out and
showing their love and support and um
super grateful for everything like
helping us with the you know the baby
registry like getting all the things
that we need because it's a lot of stuff
we realized like becoming new parents is
like a huge deal in terms of like
needing to get all the supplies but yeah
we do have a baby registry and we
actually got a p.o box recently yeah and
uh a lot of you guys in the previous
video where we were shopping yeah
everybody was kind of like messing
around like i was just learning how to
even use the stroller yeah um a lot of
you guys were saying like you guys
wanted to send us stuff or whatever so
and then also we asked in that same vlog
like would you guys care if we shared a
registry with you because i don't know i
feel kind of weird being like yeah
here's a list of presents that i want
like it's just i don't know i feel weird
about it so that's why i asked but you
offered so a lot of you guys said you
did
you're like no for sure share the
registry link so because um like we knew
that this shower was coming we were like
oh let's let our friends and family get
uh first dibs at the sh of the registry
and then we'll share with you guys and
so now after the shower has been done
now we're going to be sharing the
registry with you guys so if you want
you can check out the link in the
description okay let me make a little
pathway in here
also shout outs to my aunt she made this
it's made out of wood it's quality it's
so cute i like it it really stuck with
the space theme oh yeah by the way to
explain the space theme it's because um
casey first started calling the baby an
astronaut when we first saw baby in the
ultrasound because it just looks like a
little astronaut floating in this little
figurine floating in black space i was
like it's an astronaut so this is
actually the nursery theme when we
eventually turn the office into a
nursery
after the baby's already like i don't
know four to six months old or something
because they're gonna be sleeping in our
room anyway that's where the space theme
comes from and whether they're a boy or
a girl which to remind you guys we don't
know what we're having until the baby's
born i'm like space could be for girls
it doesn't have to just be a boy thing
so we went with space stuff your family
they're like convinced convinced super
convinced about having a girl to the t
it's like oh how's the how's me nina
like my granddaughter how is she of my
niece how's my knee sound like this this
baby's a boy
you guys are gonna look funny you should
place bets place your bets now i know
what do you guys think place your bet
all right
present time
first you pick
i want you to be involved with this too
i don't want to just be the only one
this one because this one stands out to
me because it's wrapped in a blanket you
said it was from aka yeah aka is a
friend of mine we went to film school
together moved out to l.a together so we
go way back and um
hey siri what's up
that was random is the blanket the
present too yeah it's a blanket oh cute
sing sing
oh this is awesome it's a whole bunch of
sing uh toys and coco ah
i recognize that one yeah oh babies this
is so cool that's the coolest one love
it what are these
or something nice breast milk storage
bags this is from the registry i
recognize it that's awesome i love how
he knows the essentials because he's a
dad himself thank you ak
next one
ooh
wipes
yes
who do we say thank you to
they're a silent guardian yeah they're
they're batman they're silent gifter
okay this one oh this one was from my
piano now she showed us to show it to us
yesterday look at this
so cute little baby astronaut oh this is
my dear god oh this is dope she made it
a point to show us like when she like
handed the bag over yes she's committed
amazing she placed her bets for sure she
placed her bets look at this how cute is
this oh my god imagine a little girl but
look look look look oh my god i slipped
i flipped out when i thought it was just
nice
that's awesome oh this is so cute
i love it we got a cute little purse
she wanted to have a girl
this one's from christina aunt leia and
enzo oh
cute
oh this is so cute oh look at this
that's awesome
we got some mo family merch so cute
that's sick family merch love it and a
pacifier oh nursing pads these i'm gonna
need with isaac i leaked everywhere it
was crazy tmi but whatever and then it
says
congrats you guys can't wait until a
little one is finally here from ann
christina leia and enzo we are so happy
to see your little family grow i know
everyone is going to be spoiling the
little babe but we can't forget about
mama too love you hope their gifts help
you to stay comfy guys and then a heart
oh where'd she get mama
oh yeah the nursing oh that's sick
i like that yes i am so excited about
this i saw this and i was like this is
awesome like an actual wrap because with
isaac i had a different carrier like the
pre-pre-wrapped ones or not pre-wrapped
but like the other ones yeah that was
really hard to put on so i was really
looking forward to a wrap thank you aunt
christina enzo and leia oh nice this is
this comes in clutch what is that
chapstick for your nipples yes how do i
know that yes
oh diaper
yes
we need diapers as a new father i'm
hearing on the street word on the street
is that diapers are very expensive it's
one of the biggest costs
in having a baby so according to word on
the street i am super thankful i should
be very super grateful for diapers these
are
needed and we go through so many of them
unless you decide to go with the
reusable diapers but
i'm not about that life
there's no note so
thank you anonymous another batman this
one's from my grandma
my mama's mama oh so cute
it's a blanket it says hello sunshine
because we're having a rainbow baby
that's where the rainbow theme comes in
a lot of these things and then what's
this
cbd oh
[Music]
it's dvd infused it says it's a blanket
oh i don't like it cbd infused blanket
yeah
like kind of like you know cat toys that
have a catnip in it this is like cbd for
babies yes i don't know it's pretty cool
and a row
look at this
sweet is that for you for the baby
this is a mama present okay god is the
cbd infused i want to try the cbd
infused no it's just a superstar got it
thank you grandma
it's a bottle of
wine cards yay these are from oh thank
you so much these are from my my twin
friends jessica giselle diaper monkey
yeah
oh it looks like a wine i know i like
the deception
[Music]
oh cute
keepsake box oh this is so cute
my first cure my first pacifier my first
cure what does that mean i don't know my
first booties my treasures my hospital
bracelet oh this is so cute
you know this is more of a present for
you for the parents
like a kid that's growing up is not
going to care about that
that is so cute though actually i cared
about all the things that my mom saved
for me like there's a texture i did too
yeah look for a baby girl
this also didn't come with a note i
don't know who gifted us this but thank
you so much okay
oh books yes i love this education for
the baby yeah we can read to the baby i
that's actually something i wish i did
more with isaac is read more to him like
i did read here and there but not like a
whole library kind of right it wasn't a
lifestyle it wasn't a lifestyle oh this
is so cute that's awesome little rainbow
baby
i don't see your card in here either oh
bodysuits you go through so many of
these it's a bodysuit educate me this
it's like a full oh
okay like inside like a first layer kind
of thing oh like underwear like a like
uh
got it yeah these are body suits too oh
this is so cute ready for anything yeah
i can see them in my registry because
it's all black and white like just
neutral yeah oh cute little finger
puppet book
give me your best crab voice because
when you read this book you have to put
on a show and here's a fish that's
caught inside
it's gonna be fun i love this little
finger puppet book
and
oh yes oh this is from from our
neighbors ryan and lily oh yay oh thank
you ryan and lily for all these things
the baby basics oh cool
thank you boogers yeah farts
nails flakes flakes oh i relate i have
lots of flakes oh yeah in fact i relate
to all these i have a lot of gas too
boogers yeah thank you ryan and lily and
leia layla and landon
i love this ribbon
oh there's two in here
from h m oh that is from alice and doris
i recognize her cute washi tape
tiffany casey isaac a new baby from
alice and doris and sparky how cute i
love it oh look at this
baby you're a star so they have their
own card company it's called i loot
papery.com you guys gotta check them out
if you want
cards they're so cute they're so
creative
look how pretty it's written hi tiff
case and isaac so much congrats to you
all for the soon to come baby it's been
so fun watching your journey to a family
of six because kitties and we can't wait
to meet the little one in a few months
get some rest and sleep in while you can
let us know if we can help in any way
and it's going to be amazing i love this
card over the years i always save their
cards even though they give us cards to
give to each other they're still like
they're so pretty i can't write in them
oh this is so cute
no safari bodysuit oh my gosh that's
awesome
and then look
i had this in a rush to like food and
drink cantonese oh that's sick i mean
yes and then first wonders
in spanish spanish your language
my language yeah i want to see hold on
let me see look oh dante
mongol
mongol bodies
there's actually like a whole series of
these on amazon so i'm like i'm totally
looking forward to just getting these
well we're taking this when we go eat uh
dim sum then yes we get to learn so they
get to have the real thing in front of
them while while they learn the language
you're going to learn all these spanish
words too oh it's so cute
the bath toy oh sweet they're gonna have
so much fun in the tub and look this is
so cute because it's like a little
shower too
all right this is from my mom's friend
angelica oh yes more wipes
whoa it's kind of heavy lots of wipes
448 wipes is that a lot that's a lot huh
this is awesome this is good for like
glasses to their ten yeah three months
actually for for new for newbies they
end up using a lot of wipes so i think
you're the one that's gonna use all of
these oh you're gonna have to teach me
how to maximize the usage of one wipe
well for starters what you do
if it's a poopy diaper you use the
diaper itself to wipe most of the poop
off genius exactly ooh a baby bathroom
this is really what is that kid's
photoshopped head is that kid's head
photoshop i don't know is that his
actual head from the photo
photoshop it looks like it's
like cut out i have a feeling these
might be the ones from the registry that
went straight to my mom's house so i
might need something to
open
yeah we need a
thingy this is where we keep our box
cutter just in case anybody wants to
come and mess with us at the door yeah
oh
bottles
this is from
michael
thank you michael
what
there's another gift from aunt christina
leon enzo
thank you guys
a nursing pillow
yay
okay so i also had this on my registry
and they didn't have the gender neutral
one so i got the girly one
so even you're kind of favoring the girl
even me i picked something are you
saying that you think it's a girl i
think it's a boy
but i was like you know what i'm the one
using it like the mom
right it's for you it's the color for
you it's fun and then plus boys can have
pink stuff in flower stuff too it's like
chill it's salmon it's not pink yeah see
salmon
i had a boppy which is a different
nursing pillow and i really disliked it
with isaac because in the center like it
like all the cushion would go out and so
the baby would like be dipping in my
stomach with a c-section that was rough
cool oh it comes with its own tie this
is cute i can't wait to use it thanks
guys
okay another package
oh cute
oh it's so cute this one's from my
cousin andrew who is actually trying to
be an astronaut who works for nasa he
picked the space themed stuff from the
registry it's so cute oh this one's so
pretty it's like an old-fashioned parcel
this is cute oh my gosh this is from
deanna this tip what can i say you're a
pro at the mom thing killing it as a
teen mom and look at isaac now and here
you are doing it all over again i'm so
happy you got the growing family you
worked so hard for lots of love dee and
ray oh thank you so much dee oh cute
this is a crib mobile oh that's sick i
like crib mobiles yeah this one's like
like a moon like space
i feel like one of my earliest memories
ever are images of the crib mobile that
was in my crib yeah and just like
floating above me because like i have
memories of like these weird it almost
feels
almost feels psychedelic like i'm like
what are these colors and images like i
feel like i've lived them wow like i
couldn't quite decipher what it was and
i feel i if i had a place why i have it
in my memory it's because i'm staring at
the crib uh what are these mobile crib
mobile and i'm like oh that's a whatever
that design is and and uh yeah so
if that is true then our baby's first
memories might be whatever this is
looking from the bottom up yeah you'll
be like why are all these like tiny
little blue and white and gray and dots
with stars that's it
what's the baby gonna see
that's the baby's first memories
if my theory is correct
oh cute what is it soft hooded
towels oh this is awesome you can never
have too many towels because you doing
nighttime routines you need
all the baby towels oh cute
i can't wait to wrap them in this towel
this is cool it's like long thank you d
another amazon package i'm assuming
[Music]
oh this is the other stuff from andrew
space
dry and wet bags go put um their wet
clothes wet bibs or whatever and then
this doesn't show us but from the
registry it's these like decals
or like space like to decorate the room
like a space
space theme look at this
that's awesome my brother
i can't wait they'll be taking photos
with isaac
putting in this frame
how cute oh my god it's heavy i might
have to help you lift these up well this
is really heavy
they gave a weight set to the baby yeah
oh why
yes more white 900 wipes
all right this will last us
yeah this will last a while this is
awesome
diaper
that's right oh that's awesome so clutch
yes i love it i love it size one instead
of newborn because with isaac i got
i it was like 12 boxes of newborn size
diapers i was like oh my god
i totally did not go through them at all
i think i maybe went through like five
four
i don't know so because he outgrew him
real fast yeah newborn is really small
so
let me see it's up to 14 pounds so yeah
these
thank you
last one
last one
saves the the biggest for the lastest
yes
we go i'm good i'm good oh there's a box
in a box box in a box russian doll can
you help oh my gosh it's a full travel
crib cool so it's the best net from the
registry
i'm tired
yeah so the crib that we ordered isn't
going to come in on time so i added a
best in it to the registry and i believe
i think michael got us to the basement
oh so thank you michael two gifts you're
so sweet that's it
this is amazing look at all these
gifts that our baby was showered with
where are we gonna store these until the
baby comes that's a great question
because even when the baby's here i'm
like where are we gonna put all the baby
stuff true have anywhere to put anything
our house is so small all right so we
gotta move homes before the baby comes
in two months we need to buy a new house
all right relocation time stay tuned for
the next video where we go house
shopping yeah
[Music]
you